oh this is gonna be bad you're fine just  totally  [Music]  play that  [Music]  never have I ever gotten a tattoo I  regret no you know how touching your  nose like not away now that I regret  though  [Music]  never have I ever gone skinny-dipping in  a hotel pool  he's a few thinners I'm not going to  okay should I just do the heavy shots I  believe in here never have I ever used  my name to get out of a sticky situation  what's sticky mean to house Vicki I  think yes extremely uncomfortable  adhesive value we like the orders need  to say I have  [Music]  never have I ever worn a pair of my  bandmates  underwear thank you how do you know when  Wendy was like I'll never know no no  every night we all got each other's  thought you had wore my underwear year  never have I ever said the naughty text  to the wrong person  sure you heard about it crappy story mom  you really